bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
habitat espaces verts mobilité le
développement durable est partout à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des logements
neufs performant au logement rénové
nous ferons le tour des actions et
propositions se ressourcer protéger
l'environnement faire face au changement
climatique en ville c'est possible nous
ferons le point voitures trains bus vélo
mais aussi véhicule autonome collectif
voire aérien comment ça bouge sur saint
quentin on peut le tour c'est parti
[Musique]
on habitait à paris avant on est venu
ici c'est vrai que on a une meilleure
qualité de vie avec les enfants qui ré
quoi nous on est propriétaire dans le
quartier depuis 20 ans maintenant et on
n'a pas eu ce souci de trouver
j'estime qu'il ya quand même une offre
qui représente saint quentin en yvelines
labellisé cap cit'ergie pour sa
politique en matière de climat et
d'énergie
depuis 2000 13,8 plan portant sur
diverses actions ont été adoptés sur le
territoire ceci notamment afin de
limiter les impacts dus aux changements
climatiques
le programme local de l'habitat il fait
écho adoptée en septembre dernier il a
pour objectif la création de 1700
logements par an sur le territoire
en clair c on essaie de faire des
bâtiments performants très bien isolée
avec une optimisation pour réduire les
charges et d'optimisation des économies
globales en termes d' énergétique ces
dernières années de nombreux ensembles
sont sortis de terre à guyancourt
attrape amour pas toujours moins
énergivores pour une empreinte carbone
en revue à la baisse à voisins le
bretonneux 500 logements sont prévus
dans le futur écoquartier de la remise
divers promoteurs honteux vrai ensemble
pour proposer une qualité énergétique
optimum des habitats une association qui
a permis de dégager des économies
réinjectés dans des services auprès des
habitants à l'éco-quartier ce n'est pas
qu'une performance technique c'est aussi
lusage sait on habite on se fait pas
qu'à bits et on vit aussi dans un
logement et dans un quartier on va voir
à une partie de production qui votent en
habitat participatif
ainsi les habitants de 26 logements vont
être invité à co concevoir avec le
promoteur leur futur quartier et
imaginer certains aménagements mais bien
vivre dans son logement
ce n'est pas seulement un habitat
performant la qualité des logements ça
vaut aussi dans le confort des logements
on à définir un label dédié qui
s'appelle calice qui comprend 29
critères et qui permet d'avoir
finalement qui répondent aux standards
d'objectifs de logements de qualité
c'est-à-dire des logements avec de
superficie
suffisamment confortable de logements on
respire bien des logements on à la
lumière naturelle qui rentre à des
logements qui sont bien isolés c'est
toutes ces enjeux là pour demain puisque
finalement avec du foncier public qui se
raréfie demain c'est le privé qui va
aussi continuer de construire et donc on
essaie de accompagner les promoteurs
pour répondre à nos standards de qualité
pour avoir des logements qu'ils soient
dans la durée confortable autre enjeu la
rénovation énergétique
plusieurs actions sont proposées par
l'agglomération afin d'améliorer le parc
existant
les particuliers comme les bailleurs
sociaux peuvent être accompagnés par
différentes structures qu'on a mis en
place différents outils tels que le
dispositif habiter mieux qui
accompagnent les propriétaires occupants
modestes à des travaux de rénovation
énergétique et qui sont cofinancés par
différents partenaires publics qui
permet de réduire finalement cette
facture des travaux de 25000 euros
pourront ainsi être subventionné jusqu'à
80 % le reste à charge sera donc
relativement faible pour les
propriétaires l'agglomération apporte
aussi un soutien financier de 500 euros
par dossier
autre outil la plateforme repères
habitat l'alec réalise un diagnostic
gratuit sur les travaux prioritaires à
effectuer et guide les propriétaires ou
les collectivités faire les entreprises
agréées l'enjeu c'est de massifier ses
rénovations énergétiques pour réduire
l'empreinte l'empreinte écologique
l'empreinte carbone
trouver un certain équilibre entre les
logements et l'environnement respecter
le cadre de vie des saint quentinois
c'est aussi le but du programme local de
l'habitat
et avec le changement climatique la
nature présente en ville aura de plus en
plus un rôle à jouer
moi j'aime bien ça fait 25 ans et
franchement on aime beaucoup beaucoup
c'est très charmant ils sont oui j'aime
beaucoup c'est calme pour les enfants
c'est bien aussi il ya beaucoup de
choses ont tourné tout de suite qu'on
peut aller se promener
voilà dans la forêt on peut aller courir
la base de loisirs mal parc de diane
je pense que on est déjà pas mal en
termes d'environnement je pense qu'il
fait bon vivre à saint quentin
l'environnement malgré tout il est quand
même très apprécié parce qu'on a accès
direct à la nature on n'a pas envie d'en
partir
saint quentin en yvelines possède 60%
des espaces naturels des espaces
aquatiques boisés ou encore des chants
et des étendues d'herbe 5000 hectares de
surfaces végétalisée 38 bassin de
stockage 78 mille arbres
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié du
territoire est composée d' espaces verts
le paysage de saint quentin répondent
déjà aux changements climatiques avec
tous nos espaces boisés qui sont des
vrais zillow tresher pour la population
maintenant la communauté d'agglomération
commence un travail de réintégrer un
petit peu la nature en ville même si
elle est déjà présente de l'intégrer
d'une meilleure manière de sorte à ce
que ces îlots très cher s'intègre de
plus en plus en ville avec une
végétation qui me dont l'ombre va porter
bien sûr au sol mais également sur les
façades une action complété par la
gestion différenciée des espaces verts
et notamment les tontes effectuées plus
tardivement dans la nuit ces herbes
hautes en fait vont permettre d'éviter
l'évaporation de l'eau du sol et de
garder une certaine fraîcheur du sol
pour le volet biodiversité elles vont
aussi permettre d'être terre d'accueil
on va dire pour les insectes et puis
pour la microfaune qui pu être présentes
en ville pour le côté arbustifs on n'a
pas trop de haies et d'arbustes présents
en ville c'est là l'enjeu essayer de
reconstituer des et des arbustes en plus
des arbres déjà présent elles vont
conforter l'ombre portée conforter
encore une fois cette fraîcheur
conserver et
être un vrai tissu vert au sein de au
sein du tissu urbain et au quotidien
chacun peut contribuer au développement
durable
il ya plusieurs gestes adaptés tout ce
qui est taillé tardive à l'automne tout
ce qui est du coup coupe minimum du
gazon enfin gardez les auteurs maximum
tout simplement si on a des grands
jardins même laissé des zones de
non-droit non entretenues et éviter la
taille de haies systématique et la
préférée encore une fois à l'automne ce
qui permet d'accueillir les oiseaux etc
et puis pour les arbres à minima les
laisser encore libre le plus souvent
possible sauf évidemment cela devienne
du voisinage ou de risque pour les
façades etc pour la plantation préféré
des espèces locales chaîne charme être
pour les arbres pour les arbustes le
fusain le cornouiller le sureau ou
encore l'églantier des essences qui
permettront d'alimenter oiseaux et
petits mammifères
tout au long de l'année penser à la
coupe et le dos à l'abri des prédateurs
pour qu'ils puissent s'abreuver pour les
hérissons mangeurs de limaces un simple
tas de feuilles dans un coin fera la
faire
comment améliorer la mobilité sans
impacter l'environnement
ces derniers temps l'agglomération à
privilégier le développement des pôles
gare et la multimodalité
demain elle compte sur l'innovation pour
limiter les usages du véhicule
individuel et la pollution
embouteillages bas c'est un peu comme ce
que je france on va dire c'est que
globalement assez bouché quand même avec
les enfants c'est compliqué donc du coup
on vient en voiture
on n'a qu'à se débrouiller en voiture je
pars très tôt le matin
pas de bouchons améliorer les trajets du
quotidien et fluidifier les routes ces
dernières années de nombreux travaux ont
été impulsés ou seront bientôt à
l'oeuvre le doublement du pont guy
schuller à maurepas ou de la rd 30 à
plaisir l'enfouissement de la rn10
attrape la rénovation du pont de la
villedieu
mais pour limiter l'usagé du véhicule
l'agglomération a surtout axé son plan
local de déplacement sur le
redéploiement des transports en commun
et tout d'abord la restructuration du
réseau stibus ça soit qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de bus qu'avant et que c'est plus
le sympa puis même plus tard le soir de
plus en plus je trouve quand même pas
mal de transport par man 2 lignes de bus
j'ai le choix entre le bus toutes les
demi-heures ou sinon le train
la correction se fait très bien j'ai
vraiment très peu d'attentes j'ai à peu
près cinq minutes d'attentes correct a
donc j'essaie d'être écolo et ne pas
prendre la voiture sur les communes de
plaisir les clés vivre donc le secteur
nord on a eu des améliorations et des
fréquentations très
en forte évolution d'une manière globale
de l'ordre de 4 % + donc ce qui est un
bon résultat et ponctuellement notamment
sur le week-end les samedis où l'offre a
été fortement renforcée ponctuellement
on a des chiffres qui vont de l'ordre de
30 40 % d'augmentation
et puis parallèlement on a fait aussi
des ajustements sur les offres pour les
salariés avec les lignes qui rabat
notamment les salariés vers les pôles
d'emploi de 50 ans mais aussi des
ajustements sur la ligne 4 175 qui
dessert le centre de l'agglomération
la clé saint pierre et la porte
d'orléans et la ligne 15 vers saint
claud le 5 décembre dernier deux quarts
à deux étages ont été instaurées ces
derniers mois ont aussi vu l'arrivée de
trois bus électriques
on a un retour des usagers et puis
surtout des codes des chauffeurs qui est
très satisfait puisque effectivement ça
se conduit d'une manière un peu
différente amène de la fluidité du
silence autre chantier le développement
des pôles gars on essaie très bien des
services communs trois lignes de train
donc rien à dire saint quentin qui
dessert quand même montparnasse la
défense le rer c'est donc pour ça je
pense qu'il ya eu un gros effort et
c'est quand même assez facile de se
rendre sur la sur paris on n'est pas
trop loin de paris non plus la verrière
les airs grignon villepreux les claies
trois gares concernées par les
réaménagements à la verrière le projet
comprend le réaménagement des parvis la
construction d'une nouvelle gare
routière et d'un parc relais évolutif de
750 places
le but renforcer l'intermodalité
améliorer l'intermodalité c'est la
reprise finalement d'une manière plus
fonctionnel et plus pratiques ou des
pôles gare et donc autour des pôles
garba l'interface avec les modes doux
l'interface avec les parkings avec les
voitures mais aussi les interfaces avec
les bus
exemple entre la verrière et maurepas
avec le doublement du pont guy schuller
le déploiement les pistes cyclables et
du tcsp
de son côté la bicyclette n'en finit
plus de gagner du terrain
je parle de dieu comme oubliée jusqu'à
versailles va plus chez globe
d'ailleurs ce qu'il était 423 km
d'itinéraires cyclables dont 150 dédié
au vélo sur le territoire saint
quentinois un mode de transport qui
séduit et pas seulement au sein de la
vélostation de la gare saint-quentinoise
des vélos électriques ont également été
fournies par la région pour répondre à
une forte demande et en parallèle au vu
de ces éléments là on apporte les
briques servicielle et notamment celles
à vélo station avec de la réparation des
locations de vélos le stationnement
sécurisé un stationnement sécurisé déjà
opérant dans les gares de plaisir
venions trappe villepreux les clés et
bientôt à la verrière
la bicyclette devrait poursuivre son
déploiement sur les douze communes de
l'agglomération jusqu'au géo 2024 l'idée
de trottinettes électriques quant à elle
est envisagée dans un futur proche mais
favorable à avancer sur ce dispositif
des trottinettes mais on veut pas y
aller dans n'importe quelle condition
donc on souhaite y aller dans des
conditions de sûreté et de sécurité
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient fortes et
qui s'articule bien avec les de
l'ensemble des autres modes d'autres
transports particulièrement innovants
sont à l'étude sur saint quentin en
yvelines comme les navettes électriques
suspendus supra sky autre projet avec
ile-de-france mobilité les véhicules
autonomes collectif un service qui
pourrait s'ouvrir aux saint quentinois
pour le mois de juin 2020 celui ci
viendra s'imbriquer dans l'offre des
pôles gars skient mag s'est terminée
après bientôt
ciao
[Musique]